right so let me see if I can explain
each one so moderation okay so let's try
and unpack this right every school does
things differently right so therefore if
I submit like the school gets all about
your assessments right and then we get a
set of scores from you okay
so let's suppose this is what we submit
for you guys I'll put it in rank order
okay so someone gets say 1988 okay so
suppose that's what we get out of you
guys that's how we after your
assessments have been weighted more
put-together you know this this four of
you and this is what we think of you
okay now the problem with this is that
in some ways this mark is totally
manufactured totally artificial right
because based on how I write the
assessments and how I mark like what
criteria I use and that kind of thing um
this 90 it could just as easily have
been like a 91 or a 95 like who's there
to arbitrate between whether it should
be one or the other the school is kind
of with regard to these marks is king
can do whatever lights it can submit
whatever it likes to the Board of
Studies okay and you know if I'm a bit
of a sneaky kind of teacher right and
I'm like I want my students to do really
well and you might have heard that
you've got the arm HSE final exam and
the school mark and it's 50/50 who's
heard that before they know that before
yeah okay
now here's it isn't it there are 5050
but they're not the same kind of 50
right because what if instead of this I
thought okay if they're just going to
take 50% of this mark and I want my
students to do really well right I'm
just going to say yeah they're all
awesome
right um why not just what let's stopped
me from submitting all these marks and
then the border state says oh look
they're all night I get to take half of
that and then put half of the exam okay
so these wall marks in other words that
come from the school in many ways
they're meaningless right because I can
as a teacher or as a head teacher are
more likely I can make these marks
whatever I like
okay but you still want to take them
into a cap can anyone tell me given that
they're so subjective and schools can do
whatever they like
why are school marks useful why would
they be useful to the Board of Studies
okay all right so I'm gonna get from
this rankings right now the rankings get
used ok these raw marks they're going to
get ignored in a second okay but the
rankings don't they stay okay but why
were the rankings off of the score mark
which I can just manufacture why would
they be useful and the answer is if
you're like me right and the kind of
person whew I hated final exams okay cuz
I write slow I think slow I can really
understand something but you put me in a
time pressure situation and I just I
just collapse in a heap okay so my dad
must have been bad theater soon okay but
if you say okay you know mr. win write a
speech okay and you give me like a
couple weeks to do it I will write a
killer speech I'll get 19 out of 24 okay
but that kind of thing can't be tested
by a final exam right you know the same
way for a subject like drama or visual
art okay they've got their final exam
but it's very obvious that someone who's
good at drama or visual arts may not
necessarily be good at a final written
exam because the skill sets are totally
different is that make sense so this
mark is useful number one because it
should tell me who's who's best and
who's worst right but more importantly
it shows me that ranking on the basis of
a wide range of things I can test lots
of different skills and lots of
different kinds of knowledge which are
fine electracy exam cannot do okay so
here's what happens the boy studies
looks at this okay there look at them
they look at the marks I submit as a
teacher I think about you they take the
rankings and they also take these
differences okay
so looking at this this is this what's
that 13
fifteen okay now looking at that first
thing you can tell right who is meant to
be better and whose material but
secondly you can also tell like the gap
from first to second is wildly different
from a gap to second numbered right
these two people are really close
together and these people are not right
so the Board of Studies wants to take
that into account and not just say our
first and then second and then third
this this person who's in second gets
really ripped off by that comparison
okay cuz third is like really way down
actually okay fourth is in further after
that so what is the actual process by
which they take that and put it together
with an example so this is what's called
the school assessment okay
that remark gets looked at they take the
ranks they take the differences and then
they ignore it okay so then what they're
going to do is they're going to replace
that school assessment with another math
the question is where does that come
from okay and the other mic is going to
be called because the process is
moderation they call this mark the
school moderated assessment okay who's
heard of that phrase before okay all
right I'll get going so the question is
how do they determine what these marks
are going to be so you go and do your
final exam okay so we'll call this the
Board of Studies example right and this
is out of 100 okay so you get some kind
of score right now suppose this is what
we get now this is interesting okay
because here this order of marks is
going to become surprisingly no point
it's really important for you guys who
are in math 7 to work really hard here's
why
suppose the person who's first still
comes first
okay so they get 95 okay in the person
who came second um they do well let's
see
they do pretty close okay and these two
down here this is interesting right
suppose they don't do as well as first
and second why you know before we had
like marks in the 70s and the 60s or
something tonight is that what I put
right it looks like they went really
really poorly
but what they actually get in the final
exam suppose it's quite high right
number one it smells quite high number
two suppose this guy who came forth
right actually comes third in this final
exam okay so it's like hmm if all I had
was a final exam
right then I would look at this and say
this guy is the worst guy okay this is
me this is me I crashed and burned on
the exam relatively speaking okay even
though I'm actually not that bad if you
take into account all the skills that
this subject represents okay so here's
what's actually really interesting this
is what I didn't understand okay what
they do with these marks sounds a91 is
they take the total okay now what is the
total okay
that's 1018 plus these are all going
become it's like 368 I think so island
or something like that suppose that was
the total I don't know something to
check for me um once they've got the
total okay
they now um take that total and they
just put in a big heat for the whole
school like it was alright alright so so
now this 368 right this is where they're
going to get all of your new marks from
okay this school moderate assessment
okay because what this tells you is
that's kind of how good they really you
guys really are with regard to the rest
of the state your marks here might other
pretty poor but actually you guys are
great right when we compare you with the
rest of the state this is the exam that
everyone does okay so they're going to
take this 360 a and they're going to
distribute you those 368 marks across
these four people in a way that number
one preserves their ranks and number two
preserves the distances between them
okay so I'm not sure actually how's it
going to work so there's a formula
because it did okay but whatever this
you know s sorry a/b c/d a/b c/d will
all add up to 360 eh
okay now you saw the numbers before they
weren't going to add up to 360 because
you had some really low mark to you okay
but by virtue of the fact that the final
exam shows us you guys are much smarter
and the school assessment would have
would have revealed okay
that's why everything gets sort of
pulled up as it were right so this
moderating process tells us you guys are
smart school will drag those up and it
could do vice-versa if you're a poor
school and your assessment marks look
great and your final exam your site okay
does that make sense so this is the
process of moderation right and what it
means is as well if all of your marks
together right what gets put in the heat
and then you get your score mark okay
this is why it's so critically important
that you all work together it's not like
a you know each individual how you
perform okay and this is also one of the
reasons why people who are in selective
schools get such a big advantage over
the rest of the state because obviously
all of your scores as a whole as a
cohort you're all going to lift each
other okay
so that's why I study groups are so
important because not just about you how
good you know your subject but how well
everyone does together okay is that make
sense yeah all right now what will
happen is whatever these numbers are I
put together with this mark okay and
then they go 5050 and you get what's
called your final age of summa for that
subject okay so there will be four marks
here which are averaged according to
what this moderate assessment is and
what your exam on it okay right that's
moderation